one and your live chairman thank you
thank you very much good evening and
welcome to this
council meeting on thursday the 3rd of
february
2021
my name is councillor mark hurd and i'm
the chairman of the malden district
council
this meeting is held under new
regulations which come into effect on
the 4th of april
in response to the kobit 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all please could ask everyone
present at this meeting
to ensure your microphone remains muted
when not addressing the council
this reduces background noises and
avoids unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting
you're giving consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating points of order
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions
or any other purpose when speaking and
referring to the agenda
papers please ensure you reference a
page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise
as possible when invited to speak please
ensure you turn on your microphone
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
and i'll start with mr dobson dodson
good evening paul dodson director of
strategy performance and governance
thank you mr dodson mr leslie
good evening chris leslie director of
resources
thank you mr holmes
good evening richard holmes director of
service delivery
thank you mr quelch simon
quelch and i'm one of the legal advisors
thank you mr lee
good evening members i'm matthew lee
lead specialist place
and chief plan officer at moore district
council thank you
thank you and miss bird good evening
chairman good evening members tara bird
committee services officer thank you
thank you very much are there any other
offices present
okay tara please can you now carry out a
roll call
of members to confirm who is in
attendance thank you
oh yes chairman members if you could
just indicate if you're here when i call
your name please
starting with councillor bassinger
please
present thank you thank you councillor
miss phil
councillor miss phil
present thank you very much councillor
brianville
[Applause]
i don't think he's here chairman no he's
not on the call
uh councillor bell here good evening
everybody
the castle boys here
thank you councillor mrs channel present
um good evening members good evening
miss bird
good evening council durham yeah thank
you councillor edwards
present
[Music]
thank you very much head
he's obviously present as the chairman
uh councillor helm
thank you president thank you cancer
present that's a jarvis
evening tara chairman councillors
thank you councillor keys
good evening everybody presents thank
you
cather lagan yeah good evening everybody
good evening
councillor maze present
thank you thank you morley
good evening present morris
counseling nun yes good evening sarah
good evening members
thank you council shawnessy present tara
thank you good evening members
thank you casa siddall good evening to
our president
cancer stamp good evening chairman tara
members present
thank you council stilts good evening
tara
a present that's a swain
yes good evening president named mrs
thompson
oh good evening everyone yes i'm
president thank you good evening
and councilor miss white um miss bird i
believe
i i managed to get here
i wasn't sure i was going to make it but
i'm here so good evening everybody
good evening and chairman i can just see
council brian berry's now joining us
and that is the role call thank you very
much thank you very much and uh good
evening to all all members and officers
um gender item number two is apologies
for absence so may i have the apologies
for absence please tara oh yes chairman
apologies have been received from
councillor duik
council mrs fleming and cancer skins
council schemes advises that he will try
and attend later if he can
thank you chairman thank you very much
uh it might be
um a timely reminder members
could i just remind you that any
apologies
should be sent to um committee services
and as a courtesy it's good to let the
chairman know not just
for this but for any other meetings
should go through committee services
and that way we will get the message
thank you very much
so those apologies are noted gender item
number three is declaration of interest
this is to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate
and i will invite you to speak
tara can you please advise if any member
has
indicated a wish to speak yes chairman
and
councillor mrs chandler council durham
carson lagan and councillor stamp have
all indicated they wish to speak
thank you thank you very much councillor
channel
uh thank you very much chairman uh it's
my normal declaration chairman in
um i'm sorry my printer's starting to go
berserk
um that um i'm um an essex county
councillors brothers and walden district
council many items of
tonight actually do relate to essex
county council because obviously we're
in partnership or
certain things we work together on so
any matter pertinent to essex county
council tonight i declare that
non-beginning which is most items on the
agenda german
thank you council channel councillor
durham thank you chairman i have a
non-pecuniary interest as a member of
essex county council
uh uh pertaining to any items on the
agenda that them
so in that authority thank you thank you
very much
councillor lagan thank you chair
just non-pecuniary uh declaration and
item number 18
i've had previous correspondence with
that organization
thank you very much that's noted and
councillor stan
uh thank you chairman i actually put my
hand up towards the end of the last
agenda item and before everybody did for
this agenda item
because i wanted to let people know that
councillor morris was having difficulty
logging on chairman but obviously i'm so
small
i was missed thank you
okay apologies for that um counsellors
jenna
and durham you've still got your hand up
apologies chairman thank you very much
okay um i'm right insane tara that we're
keeping cameras on at the moment is that
correct
yes chairman that is correct cameras on
please where possible we understand
obviously some members do have
um broadband issues but yes where
possible please chairman
and chancellor has his hand up
thank you all right okay i can't see
that so thank you for that
counselor
right i think we're all ready to go then
on agenda item
number four um these are the minutes
from the 17th of december 2020 and it's
recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 17th of december 2020 and these are
found
on pages 7 to 20 are approved as a true
and accurate record
i so move if you wish to second that
motion
please unmute your microphone and state
your name
now councillor maze
out of mind thank you very much
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of accuracy
please use the hands up function to
indicate and i will
invite you to speak
uh i can't see any hands tara do you
have any indications
uh no chairman i don't and just to
advise chairman that council morris is
now on the call with us thank you
okay welcome councillor morris can you
hear me okay
good evening yes i can share thank you
very much welcome
um members do we wish to agree those
minutes by ascent
agreed agreed agreed
agreed thank you very much
agenda item five uh is public
questions i can advise you that we have
not received any questions
from the public i'll move on now to
agenda item number six chairman's
announcements
i do have i do have one announcement i'd
like you to
note that our flag has been lowered at
half
mast this is an exceptional case in
respect
of the passing of captain sir thomas
moore
the army veteran who raised over 32
million pounds
for the nhs i mentioned this as we are
currently working
in partnership with the nhs during this
coveted crisis
i'd like us to take just a moment to
remember his achievements
and inspiration as well as all those
who have lost their lives through
covenage
thank you members may i also um thank
all
council staff for their continued
efforts to keep our services going
uh it's important for the public to know
this
because they have been working
tirelessly so
my thanks to them
i now move to agenda item seven
which is the the minute book uh this is
the
performance governance and audit
committee on the 14th of january
2021 these are contained on pages 21-26
and i call on councillor mrs stilts to
present the minutes
councillor stilts thank you mr chairman
mr chairman members of the council i
present the minutes of performance
governance
and audit committee meeting held
remotely
on the 14th of january 2021
these are found on pages 21-26
and propose their ex reception and
adoption
i'm going to have a second after that
councillor mays thank you
i give you pages 21
22
23
24 25
and 26 is a blank page
iso move thank you
uh councillor stilts tara has anyone
indicated that they wish to speak
uh no chairman they haven't thank you um
can we
agree those by ascent please the great
upgrade agree great
thank you very much and thank you
councillor stilts
um agenda item 7b joint standards
committee
from the 26th of january uh i call on
councillor passenger to present the
minutes and one recommendation contained
in the minute
council of messenger thank you mr
chairman
uh chairman members i present the
minutes of the joint standard committee
meeting held remotely
on the 26th of january 2021
found on pages 27 to 30
and po and propose their reception
and adoption could i have a second
please
council amaze
and these are found on pages 27
28 29
minute item 9 appointment of new
independent person and reserve
page 30 an iso move
thank you councillor messenger has
anyone indicated they wish to speak
torah
sorry chairman no they haven't not for
this item okay
uh so members okay are we able to agree
those minutes by a stand
agreement there is a recommendation in
those minutes on page 29
just so that members are aware
are we happy to approve that
recommendation members
agreed great agreement
agenda item number eight uh is minutes
of the meetings of the count of the
council uh this is to note that since
the last meeting
of the council and up until wednesday
the 27th
of january 2021 the committees
listed have met and receive any
questions in accordance with council
and committee procedure rule 6-2
any member wishes to raise a question in
relation to the minutes of this meeting
please make this known by using the
hands up function
tara has anyone indicated they wish to
speak and no chairman nobody has thank
you thank you very much
um again members are we happy to
uh accept those by ascent
agreement agreed upgrade agreed
thank you very much agenda item
nine questions in accordance with
procedure rule six three of which notice
has been given i can advise
that we have not received any questions
in accordance
with this procedure rule
i now move to agenda item 10 which is
the
climate emergency statement
and these are found on pages 31-34
in a moment i'll call on the leader to
present
this item members again if you wish to
speak
please use the hands up function and
i'll come to you in turn
please ensure your points are clear
and succinct so i now call on the leader
to introduce the report leader
thank you chair um i'd like to present
this report to all members of the
council
um to the recommendation is to approve
the council of dots and publishes the
climate emergency statement
attached as appendix 1. i'm going to
call on mr dodson
to present the report but members i'd
just like to say that
we have been looking at trying to
introduce this for some time
and i think we're a little bit behind
the pace because i know essex county
council have done some fantastic work
and hopefully we will be able to work
closely with them there's other partner
agencies that have put
training sessions information together
and i think it's really important now
that we do address
there is a climate emergency going on
and i think we all need to start to
adhere to
the government guidance coming from
central government and we all need to
play our part now
so if i can hand it over to mr dodson
chairman
he can actually present it and then
members can ask any questions if they so
wish
thank you chair thank you later mr
dodson
yes thank you chairman um yes as the
the leader said um a number of councils
have um
already declared a climate emergency
and this is this was largely in response
to the
inter-parliamentary climate commission
of the united
nations that advised that we have until
2030 to take urgent action on climate
change
in order to keep the earth's rising
temperature below 1.5 degrees
celsius in in declaring this
um emergency it's really a statement of
intent that will be followed up
by a climate strategy um that looks to
look at how the council can then address
those issues
particularly around its own estate but
also work with partners
across the district to to address the
issues
within the district um cumbria county
council's
currently undertaking a climate
commission which is also something that
we can work with them
on a county-wide basis to address some
of these issues
so the um the statement itself is
attached as appendix one
for members information and and to adopt
thank you
thank you very much um so the
recommendation is set out in the report
and it's attached as it appendix one
so if any member wishes to second the
motion
please unmute your microphone council
amaze
council amazed um
councillor chan i see you have your hand
up
um that's for late well if we're going
to open the debate sorry and perhaps i
clicked it on a bit too quickly thank
you very much
assuming we're going to be able to ask
questions and have a debate that's all
indeed we are yes indeed um
so i'm going to invite members to make
any comments
tara has anyone indicated they wish to
speak i secret um
swain has yes chairman councillor swain
and kelsey council mrs channel
okay well i'll take i'll take cancer
china first as her hand was up first
no i don't mind chairman i'm quite happy
to give way to council swain because i
did get it up ego
and turned it off so he did come in
before me okay thank you councillor
swain
okay yes thank you chairman um
yes the it all sounds looks very
dramatic
saying emergency but then the situation
is dramatic and
the consequences of climate change could
be
dramatic to say the least um it's not so
long ago
that we were all bothered about where we
were going to get enough oil and gas
from
now suddenly there's been a realization
very quickly that
we have to try and do without these um
and i think the
change in public perception um about
climate change
has been mirrored by the fact that
climate change is
happening very quickly but it's an
enormous task
and that's why the urgency is to get on
with it
now um although the time scales and the
government is 2050
we've set 20 30. this is fairly short
time scale getting it giving the
fundamental things that have to be
changed
oil coal and gas has been fundamental in
our society
ever since james stephenson watched a
pot boiling
the esses county council um set up a
climate commission a year or two ago
and they already issued an interim
report which i would recommend
people to um have a look at a week or so
ago i went to the
um what's called a district um climate
action forum
uh where all districts could be present
it was under councillor walsh of
county council and it was evident there
that we are behind some and some have
gone quite a long way
in introducing measures for energy
conservation
and use of renewable energies uh now for
as far as we're concerned the district
council i think there are three
three areas that we need to take action
on
one is to look at our own activities to
look at our carbon footprint and see
whether we can use renewable energy
and take conservation measures the
second is to promote whatever schemes
are available
to businesses and households in the
district
to implement conservation measures or
use renewable energy and lastly and
perhaps most importantly
with the ldp being revised
i think we have to look very closely um
at the new ldp to make it consistent
as far as possible with these climate
change ambitions um thank you i think we
need to move
now on it urgently
thank you council swain councillor china
now
uh well that's it i'm sorry i couldn't
get my uh
mute off there for a moment um thank you
very much chairman um
and um councillor swain has targeted a
bit where i was going to be coming from
um within the report it does uh make
reference
um to a strategy as well
climate change strategy um could i
please ask when that might be coming
forward because i am aware
that this actually has been in train for
quite a while it's been
reported to performance governance and
audit for some while
and it says to develop a climate just
you know my understanding is this has
been in train for
oh must be many many months now and i
think it all goes back really to 2019
when the um the then statement was given
highlighting all this and the work to be
done in a statement i think the then
leader
and most certainly covered issues which
councilor swains referred to which about
looking at our own footprint that was
very much i can recall being in that
statement
and also we set up the air quality
management um
plan which has now got an action plan
and we've already highlighted that and
i'm
reports today in the press actually i'm
pleased to see they've picked all this
up and
aware of what the council has previously
agreed so
my point is on that in the climate
strategy can i be given an indication of
when that will come forward because as i
say
it has been reported to pga um under
audit as well and it is on the agenda i
know mr geller
has been working on this for quite some
period i appreciate with covid
there may be um matters about that
coming forward but i would perhaps like
an indication
and also regarding going back to 2019
when it was agreed
most definitely following the leaders
statement about looking at our own
carbon footprint
and indeed about the offices being you
know moving
and i didn't quite see that reflected in
the climate emergency statement it
mentioned
ensure that all our strategic decisions
budgets and approaches to planning
decisionary alarming the shift to net
zero carbon by 2030
but i'm not sure that covers what's
already been agreed over 18 months ago
about the council and uh moving an eco
with our with our partners as well that
are in the building
um to deal with this issue and certainly
looking at the um
carbon footprint we as an authority
change and you know that goes to things
like the carpooling the officers might
dr
um utilize for journeys and regarding
planning decisions i'd like to know what
we mean by that approaches to planning
decisions are we talking about
um what is it heat source pumps um
or something so i'm glad that this is
probably going to be picking up what was
agreed in 2019
in terms of the council looking to move
and also
the other matters of the air quality
because we've already got a plan agreed
back in 2020 that covers a five-year
period
and our air quality management plan
which actually takes in
market hill and the high street and i'm
very pleased with the work going on
there but there are some items
very early on when it was first set back
up must be oh
over a year ago now which i would like
to know how they're progressing because
they were addressing
issues to do with uh you know
carbon footprint okay thank you very
much for that
um mr dodson can you help with any of
those points
uh thank you chairman yes there was um
quite a few points in there but i think
um
take take the key ones um i think
there was an agreement and it was in the
the previous uh
order current corporate um plan that we
would start
developing um an environment strategy
unfortunately with with covid and the
issues that were faced over the last 12
months
uh progress has been relatively slow
on that and this is an opportunity to
to reframe that and focus on the some of
the
climate elements of that um within the
new strategy
that will be developed so to reframe the
work slightly
um i also think that the opportunity
that we have around looking at the local
development plan gives it gives us an
opportunity to look at the
the green policies within that and
ensure that we um
update any policies as we go through the
the upcoming review that's due as the
um plan approaches its um fifth year
um so that that's an update i'm happy to
answer any other questions if there are
any
okay thank you could i just remind
members to turn your cameras on where
possible please
thank you councillor lagan is next
thank you chair um there's a couple of
um
comments and a question really uh the
first one is i have a
personal um issue with declaring a
climate emergency
um although i understand that excuse me
this is
the common languaging that people will
accept
um and i think it's uh the content and
the the just
sort of strategic direction of which it
needs to move on is
is sound you can't
change the past but you do have an
opportunity to influence the future
and i think that the the aspiration
which is the thing that reached out to
me
was looking at okay what do we need to
do
to go forward to support this incredibly
challenging
time scale of 2030 so it's bigger than
selling a building or turning into
electric cars and buses
they all fall part of that strategies as
councillor channel has quite rightly
said
but i think that you know we we need to
be very clear
uh on what we can achieve the
technologies that are evolving and
moving along
and and reach out to stakeholders and
other partners so that we can actually
get informed
uh of the latest technologies because my
my fear
is that it's a very ambitious target and
there's nothing wrong with being
ambitious
um but learn from our past but really
bring forward for the future what's
actually needed
um and just to be pedantic unfortunately
there's a typo in the fourth paragraph
down in the aspiration
um it talks sorry in the second
paragraph it talks about
um relevant ages towards making more
than doing strict and its parishes
just if we publish this i think that
should just be rectified chair
thank you thank you very much for that
i'll just before i go to on to anybody
else councillor chana did you want to
come back on a particular point but i
must ask you to be brief please you have
had your
time um well yes um just regarding um
planning applications how we're going to
make sure of that
that was um an item chairman that i did
mention
in in my thing and also the highlight
would it be beneficial to put in the
statement about
the council moving because that was
agreed as i say back in
um 2019 is that i mean i know we've
mentioned budgets and everything but i
was really meaning should that not be
actually entered in there
because it had been agreed under the
previous administration as i say in a
leader statement
okay thank you mr johnson did you want
to say anything on that
um one i think the planning decisions i
referred to the the review of the ldp
which would be
updated and any policies um that would
be
directly enable um new policies new
decision making
would be through through that ldp review
process
um in terms of the um
moving from the offices i understood it
was the the
leader made a statement regarding
previous leader made a statement
regarding
um that approach and it was something
that started to be
looked into but i didn't um understand
that it had
been passed by council that that was
um yes a clear intention of the council
that that would
definitely happen so i think it appeared
in his speech it was aspirational
actually i've got to i've got
councillors white
durham and morley that that's the order
i'm going to take them um
because that's the order that i've seen
it so i'll go next to councillor white
oops thanks thank you mr chairman and
i'm sorry
i've kind of lost my placement i've just
heard one of my very good friends wives
has just passed away this afternoon with
chronovirus so i'm a bit i'm a bit
stunned by that i knew she wasn't well
but
um anyway what i wanted to raise um i'm
a bit surprised that this report makes
no mention
of the rams and zlois
um because obviously the those of us
have been on the council of some time
we put quite a lot of work in these
notice they perform an spd
and i just wonder if there's any
particular reason why they um
weren't included because obviously it's
all relative to climate change and the
mitigation and how we're going to
improve things going forward it was just
a
question really
johnson are you able to answer that
yes thank you chairman i mean this
really is a statement of atten
intent it's a climate emergency
statement reference to all of that that
planning policy and yes rams is a
clearly an important part of that would
be included in the
the climate strategy as it's developed
that this was primarily a statement of
intent
to to highlight the emergency and that
the council will respond to it
okay thank you thank you councillor
durham next
year thank you chairman chairman you
know we have a climate emergency
and i just find trouble just saying
we're going to make a statement saying
there's a climate ask you to put your
camera on please cancer
it is on is it yes
it's definitely on at my side okay
um yeah thank you very much some can see
me
um so yes chairman you know let's let's
not have words
of declare oh deal isn't it terrible
we've got a climate emergency let's have
some action
you know that's why essex formed the the
climate
uh commission rather than just saying
we're in an emergency
let's see some action to my knowledge
not a single counselling building has a
solar panel on it
apart from the charging point outside
the council offices not a single council
car park has an electric charging point
so and as councillor swain has said
we're miles behind other councils now we
did
um the previous leader did put it in the
aspirations and
and that that work had started um it
wasn't just pie in the sky
we we really need to start getting a
grip on this
because you know some people say oh well
it's it's a low rubbish but it isn't a
load of rubbish
we the weather is testament to it and
those living near the coast
see the implications of rising
water levels so you know whether we call
it a climate emergency statement or an
action plan let's not just say oh dear
isn't it a pity we're in trouble
let's actually get down and do something
please
thank you thank you councillor durham
councillor morley
thank you chairman just a short uh
couple of questions to mr dobson really
um i know electric perhaps is the
short-term future at the moment but has
he had
um i know we've got some rather clever
people in haybridge for
further development of other sorts of
energy
have they come forward and also have
plastics and polythene been affected
with
exports to the european um union
does he know because i know there was a
bit of a hiccup has that been
resolved at all thank you
mr johnson are you able to help on that
alternative energy in in terms of the
the first point
we've not we're not in direct
discussions around um
energy with the the reference to
haybridge but
obviously we work with as it says in the
statement work with partners
across the district um in terms of the
um the recycling i don't know
all of the the details of the impact of
the the eu but the
the market for recyclables has dipped
considerably
over the last couple of years and it's
clearly affected um
our um our contract in terms of
collecting those
recyclables and the return on them
um which i think is is reflected in the
worldwide market as much as anything
that's happened
within the eu but happy to take that
away and look if
look at if there's any particular issues
and feed it back to the member
yes and indeed that's uh that's exactly
what this debate is about now
although um council the stamp leader
although although you were next
uh councillor fluker has asked to speak
did you want to speak
now or or did you want to uh speak at
the end
i'll speak at the end thank you thank
you and this is well-placed chairman
this is councillor morris
okay can't i'll have you all
please okay uh councillor fluker
yeah thank you chairman i i hope you can
hear hear me i i just
i i just lost uh connectivity then
um chairman i think uh both councillor
chana
and uh councillor darum both alluded to
my speaking
my speech in 2019 um
at which time i made it absolutely clear
that the aspiration of this council
should be to be carbon neutral by
2023 and i know that we've done an awful
lot of work to make sure that that
happens
but of course over the last year or so
uh for variety of reasons we've not been
able to bring that work forward
and and chairman as far as the the
council's offices are
concerned and you know we have this
strange mix of old and new buildings
some of them are very efficient some of
them are not efficient
and it's the ones that not that are not
efficient
that are absolutely leaking leaking the
equivalent of carbon
and one of the main reasons
for looking at relocating the council
offices was to try and move to somewhere
which was far more
environmentally friendly so that we
could send out a message
to residents and businesses
that we were going to be at the
forefront of
this issue of climate change and how to
mitigate it so
chairman merely for clarification and i
do hope
chairman that this administration takes
this
up and supports this motion this evening
or this recommendation thank you
thank you councillor fluker councillor
morris next
thank you chairman i'd just like to take
this opportunity
to remind councillor durham council
fluker and
uh all the other conservative
councillors that the current
uh leadership team have only been here a
few short months
the independents have only started in
november and we do
intend to get things done and as far as
council fluke is
concerned a man that's driving a big
you know massively polluting mercedes
around
isn't the best person to talk about the
environment thank you
chairman i determined point of order i
take massive exception of that
my my my gas guzzling mercedes
has some of the lowest emissions that
you can have with a petrol car
great technology provided by the germans
and if nobody believes me
uh i don't i'm below cat five so well
check the mpg of it adrian chairman
thank you very much um german
sorry point of order i must actually
come in there
that is not something that is sensible
or
should be coming forward in this kind of
debate talking about
vehicles that people are driving i'm my
self-driver vehicle
and you know sort of criticizing people
the vehicles they may be driving i don't
think is something that should come into
this debate at the council general it's
getting
very impossible
right you shouldn't be speaking about
saving the environment when you've got
gasoline
power i wish to make chairman i will
deal with this outside thank you
councillor
i'm going to move to councillor helm
please
thank you mr chairman through you um
there was bits in the paper about the
council offices changing
hgv is changing and all the rest of it
um the council offices have been on the
agenda for a long time
hgvs the only way to reduce them
properly is to go electric um
stevenson's bus the well-known company
in our district
but the bus use group we asked about
going electric he said well if you want
the lights to go out and moulding
then we'll go electric so that's the
problem we have we haven't got the power
to drive all these new electric things
and we rely heavily on that little cable
that runs underneath the channel
you know what the eu's like at the
moment they can switch it off in a
moment
thank you thank you councillor helm
um council stamp i'm going to go to
councillor civil next unless you want to
come back yet
and councillor durham
okay councillor siddal next please thank
you chairman uh
it's interesting some of the statements
that are being made tonight when the
conservatives
were in this administration for such a
long time
um and in terms of these measures that
yeah they have been muted in the past
but but no action seemed to be taken
and the independent administration has
only been in
uh power since last november and it's
fantastic
that we have brought this forward report
so quickly
in terms of the council offices that was
never discussed
at full council it as mr dodson said it
was just something that was discussed in
the background
and the only thing that i really
remember
in terms of this was the previous leader
saying things in the press about it it
was never discussed
at council and it was never discussed in
terms of moving the council officers
to save energy thank you
thank you i'm going to go back to
councillor durham you said a short point
if it is a short point could you
please make it counselor it is very
short i just forgot um on the back of
what councillor swain was saying about
the ldp
of course it won't have escaped members
notice
that from um 2025
all new properties are banned from
putting in gas boilers so
you know this is just around the corner
so that that is obviously going to be an
integral part of
um not just our ldp but national
building
national building standards and um so
you know chairman i i i you know please
let's just
get on with things um i i might just
remind members that
at our last meeting we recently uh
agreed
um capital bill bit capital bids uh to
purchase two new diesel
uh trucks but um there you go
too little too late uh now uh councillor
chana and councillor
fluka have already spoken i'm just going
to go to councillor stamp
next please all right german i'll wait
uh
you know as long as it's going to be a
constructive debate and not just point
scoring if that's all right
well that i see that the two hands have
gone down so i'll go
finally to you councillor stan uh thank
you chairman i'll put my hand down
members um mr dodson and i have talked
about this
quite quite some length and i would like
to applaud him for bringing this and
being brave
but i do actually don't agree with the
actual amount of knocking he's just had
him in the offices have been dealing
with covid um
the other councillors have turned around
and said about the previous
administration and as i said i don't
want to post school so i'm not going to
go there
but but mr dodson's got some fantastic
ideas in his team
they've gone through the transformation
everybody keeps singing their praises
but everybody's now telling him and his
team to get on with it
we have to be patient they have got a
strategy they are working on it
just because it hasn't been brought to
this council yet
doesn't mean to say they're not working
in the background members it's always
been the case
and i absolutely commend them and we are
going to
work hard together to bring this because
it is a climate emergency
and i'd actually hope that members come
alongside to actually support them
rather than say things like you need to
get on with it
please give them a bit of a break thank
you chairman
and i still propose that we recommend
the statement
we could have held it off but we want to
move things forward
thank you okay um
council helm you have already spoken is
it is it uh
to continue on something that has been
said
what's that yeah is that a legacy hand
no i've just put it up again sir um
i would just say going to say that what
we need is a real expert to look at this
and we have one that was born in this
district
and he's recently been knighted on the
new year's honors list
he specializes in this sort of thing and
uh
he was awarded a knighthood for his
contribution to
energy environment and everything else
so if you want his name i will give it
to you later on
thank you thank you very much councillor
maddie thompson
sorry thank you chairman um i don't
believe certainly from our side any
criticism was meant of
mr dodson um he and his staff and about
all our staff
that have indeed done a wonderful job
and any decisions on climate change have
to be made by
members it is not up to him and nobody's
blaming him certainly we're not
thank you thank you very much
um i think uh councillor jarvis next
thank you chairman yeah i just wanted to
say i think you know it is a good paper
and
i'm involved in climate change
initiatives uh
in in london in the city and for the
city in general
and i'd be very happy to get involved
and support
officers in putting together such a
strategy which i think is the first
starting point
um if as and when officers wish to
embark on that
i think we all know there are lots of uh
lots of conferences this year
uh there's a big conference in glasgow
in november cop 26 that's a worldwide
uh conference and i think yeah it's the
right time to put an
initiative together all companies are
going to have to pay attention to
climate change there are going to be
financial penalties
applying to those companies that don't
so for those of us that think this is an
issue that's sort of just dragged on and
we can
we can sort of uh you know take take a
while to do something you know that is
wrong there is going to be
a big push this year for all companies
and and obviously councils to do
something so
i just want to offer my support to the
officers there i'm very happy to get
involved with that
share my experience that i've got as i
say i'm involved with this
with the lord mayor and city in the
london so i'm very happy to share my
experience
i'm sure other councils will volunteer
as well thank you chairman
thank you councillor jarvis that's much
appreciated um
i'm i'm going to move to the to uh to
the vote now but i see councillor fluke
you've got your hand up again is this
for a point of clarification
well chairman i i was actually going to
propose because i didn't hear that i
didn't hear the
to do it but i was actually going to
propose that we agree this
recommendation because i think
everything aside we all agree with it
chairman and uh
and i commend the leader for bringing
this forward so quickly thank you
thank you so the recommendation is that
the council adopts
and publishes the climate emergency
statement attached at appendix one
can we agree that by ascent agreed
great great great
thank you the previous leader and we
really value your expertise in helping
us
and but we can manage this ourselves and
if people allow me to speak it was
proposed
and we i would have reminded the
chairman because he's got a promise
that it needed seconding but thank you
for your help um yes it was proposed at
the beginning chairman
we do need a second and i'm more than
happy to second this thank you
thank you so can we agree that members
agreed
thank you very much thank you
uh councillor helen you still got a
legacy hand up
uh right yes i'm advised it was uh
seconded by councillor maze in the
beginning
but okay we'll move on now to
agenda item 11. this is the member
training and development plan
again members i will ask the leader
to present this in a moment please use
the hands up function
i'll come to you in turn and please keep
your points clear and succinct
uh leader please present the report
thank you chair this is great i think
we've been asking for more member
training
for quite some time especially since we
were elected in may 2019 anyway
so the purpose of the report is quite
clear is to provide the detail and
member training and development plan for
adoption
the recommendation chair recommendations
are
the adoption that that the council of
the councillor training and development
plan has set out in appendix a be
adopted
little two the compulsory member
attendance where relevant we agreed
chairman and little three the further
scoping of the full course details to be
delegated to the director of strategy
and performance and governance
in consultation with the leader of the
council
i'm going to ask i don't know if it's um
mr dodson who's going to present this uh
item or if it's going to be uh miss
hughes chance chairman thank you
just before we do just before we do that
um i need to have that
uh the motion um seconded second
council amazed okay i think councillor
siddall just beat you to it um
councillor may so i'm grateful for that
um so i'm going to uh in
i'll hand over to mr dodson
thank you chairman um yes as the leader
said following discussion
at council on the 5th of november
members requested that the high-level
training and development plan
um be further developed with training
outcomes identified
for it to be signed off fully by council
since then officers have been in
discussions with training specialists at
the local government association
who are able to deliver some of the
identified modules with no cost to
molden district council
a draft timetable of the member training
and development is a product provided at
appendix one
and it has a column of attendees and
highlights expected
or compulsory members member
attendance we've only identified
compulsory sessions
where the constitution already required
member training as part of their
committee responsibility
um but a lot of the training is highly
encouraged especially as
we're being gifted the expertise of the
local government association
appendix one also identifies who the
training would be led by and whether
this would be
a local government association or mdc
staff
appendix 2 there's a table that sets out
the expected course content and outcomes
uh the report gives more detail of
course outcomes and delivery
and seeks the delegation of the strategy
to the strategy performance and
governance director
to finalize the details but most of the
details are there it's just those final
specifics and
and finalizing the dates of the course
thank you chairman
thank you mr dodson uh tara has anybody
indicated they wish to speak
yes chairman councillor civil wishes to
speak thank you
thank you very much german uh training
you know i'm going to speak on training
as it's my favorite topic or one of my
favorite topics
i i think the the program is is
excellent and
it is the thing that we need uh it's
something that
i know since i got elected in may 2019
i've been desperate for more structure
and more focus
in terms of ensuring that we as members
have the right skills and abilities
to do our function and to do our job
effectively
i would like to put an amendment to
little three though um and my amendment
to
little three is that when the further
scoping the full
details um it be delegated the director
of resources
and i i think in consultation with the
leaders
is is limiting this consultation and
limiting this scoping
so my uh personal recommendation is that
consultation
will be in a working group with the
leader and deputy to the council
and all chairmen of committees
because i feel that for example as
chairman of strategy resources yeah i
want to ensure that
my members have the right skills to to
effectively run
uh that particular committee and also
in terms of things like overview and
scrutiny i think it would be really
important
um that the chairman of ovue and
scrutiny is involved in
deciding what training has to take place
and so on joint standards for example
disciplinary uh panels yeah we need to
we need to ensure that when we devise
this training
that the people and members of the
committee are consulted
as to where they feel that those gaps
might be so therefore the ma the
training can be as tailored as possible
thank you i'll second that amendment
thank you leader
right thank you i see that we have uh
other hands
uh now uh i think it's councillor
swain uh tara am i right
before council swaggy's council mrs
channel and then following council
swanees councillor stamp
council fluker and councillor mrs
thompson thank you
thank you councillor china
thank you very much chairman um yes um i
welcome
this report and yes it does follow on
from the meeting and i can recall that
meeting well it's good to see the extra
detail
i actually didn't have a problem
necessarily with the leader of the
council dealing with it to be frank
but if the leader is happy to accept
that amendment
um then i guess that's okay but i think
it would have been quite a good way
and i'm sure there'd be opportunities
throughout the training process to ask
relevant questions
and nub it down could i just ask just uh
having read through it
there's a couple of very good uh
documents from the ldn i'm very pleased
to see the lga involved and indeed paz
um i think that's i've been to one of
their training sessions on planning and
that was excellent
um will the code of conduct and that be
taking into account
or will it come up about the new model
one that the lga
has just recently um come forward with i
might be jumping the gun on that
uh because they've just issued one
following some um you know looking into
matters
and also there's a very good document
from the lga and i think
training is not only about how we act in
the council but how we met to help us do
our jobs does he actually mean
with residents as well and the lga have
undertaken a survey
and looked into things and apparently
there is quite an increase
across all councillors not just our
council i'm not saying occurs in our
councils about um abuse and harassment
to actually members
sometimes from members of the public and
they've bought um
a document out that covers this and
telling you how you should get support
from the
within the authority um etc so i'm
hoping it may
actually be encapsulating that and that
might be the finer detail that was going
to be in the hands
of the leader originally with mr dodson
okay thank you very much councillor
swain
yes thank you chairman um yes i i object
to um
the second recommendation
there clearly are one or two cases where
people have to um
have training um because it's part of
the conditions of
being on a particular committee but the
idea of saying
that any of it could be compulsory as
well meaningless because
attendance can't be compulsory there is
no sanction
and it must be left to members to decide
um when
and i hope they will take up um maximum
opportunity of the training but it's up
to individual members to decide
whether they feel like they wish to
take part in any particular training
other than that
that is sort of legally required
thank you that's uh that has been noted
uh councillor stamp
next chairman that was legacy
thank you uh councillor fluker
yeah thank you chairman i i just want to
pick up on the point that councillor
swain said because
recommendation to roman two i mean
that's that's a very tricky one because
if you've got somebody that's been
appointed to
a committee by council and then for any
reason that they can't undertake the
training because they work during the
day
and uh that that is terribly unfair
so i think to make it compulsory
attendance i think it
probably a better word councillor swain
is probably ahead of the curve already
and he's probably seen
saying it as compulsory training would
be better because
attendance sort of says you must go on
that day now we don't want to do that to
members
and what we want to say is that you must
have the training um
so chairman i i hope that perhaps
councilman swain and mr dodson between
them
can come up with a better uh
recommendation at two i think it's
compulsory that you have the training
but attendance at the training i'm not
sure
maybe i've not read it properly but i
think i have thank you
thank you for that uh council luca
councillor thompson next
um thank you chairman actually it was a
very quick query i wondered if counts
um to include planning chain in his
working group
just i'm just wondering that's all i did
counselor thompson
thank you thank you
i i'll i'll move now to councillor hull
and then council a nun
oh great oh thank you thanks chairman um
i'd just like to say i'd be grateful for
any training so
the more that can be thrown at us the
better really thank you
thank you very much councillor nunn um
unless i misunderstood chairman did mr
dodson not say that roman numeral 2
relates to
training that's already compulsory
uh under our arrangements so there's no
change there
and i seem to remember the previous
leader insisting when
i first became a councillor that i had
to attend
uh planning training otherwise i
couldn't serve on a planning committee
so i don't think anything's different
here at all under
roman numeral uh chairman point of order
that
that was actually a requirement set by
council not by me
and i think it's terrible to say that
against me chairman
and i actually see it and i really do
see it from councillor nunn
as an opportunity to bully me and it
should not be allowed
that was decided by council it's
actually
point of all the chairman council
the last person to be uh claiming
bullying
in this chamber he's out of order for
suggesting that
all right i i don't think that's uh
i'm going to go back to i'm going to
refer back
sorry i've been accused here of uh
bullying and uh that's certainly uh i've
never been accused of that before and
that certainly wasn't my
intention but it's a fact that the
previous leader is the person who told
me that now it may well be
and i did say actually that mr dodson
said it was already
in a a compulsory training area so
i i was simply stating a fact that the
previous leader is the person who told
me that and i attended it adrian fluker
is the biggest bully in the chamber
okay um councillor channel you've
already spoken on this i'm going to go
back to the leader now
with there has been an amendment
to two and three leader
um chad i didn't think there was an
amendment to two nobody actually said
what the amendment was going to be so
can i have clarity
if if the person i don't if it's cancer
swaying or counsellor fluka
was going to propose an amendment to
roman 2 or little to as we call it
i know councillor swains excuse me to
rupture your chair but no cancer
siddal did and i think tara would have
noted that
chairman so if tara could help us on
that one but we just need clarity on
little too
yes i can i can say that it hasn't been
proposed but councillor fluke has
suggested that compulsory
uh training where relevant be agreed he
has to propose
properly though chair i can't just leave
you
is that a proposal counselor fluke
kevin yes it is and i'll certainly make
that in
in line with what councillor swain said
i don't think we should make anything
you know compulsory attendance is
terrible i mean you know we
know we're all working we're all doing
different things i think
the the training should be compulsory
but not the attendance and and
i mean i i very much welcome mr dodson's
comments on this because i think that's
important because
he and uh miss hughes
are charged with organizing this and we
we actually want this to be
as easy as possible for them um and we
certainly don't want to hog tie them in
any way but i think that's the right way
about
to go about yes i was about i'm grateful
for that i was about to go to mr dodson
i think he's happy to explain about uh
compulsory so mr dodson
yes thank you chairman um as i said in
the the introduction
where the training is outlined as
compulsory it will only be in line with
what already exists within the
constitution and has already been agreed
by council examples of that include
licensing committee
where where um training is necessary and
some of the planning training
for example we wouldn't be looking to
introduce any
finn as compulsory attendance over and
above what council has
already agreed and is enshrined in the
the constitution
thank you thank you very much
um councillor fluker has that answered
your question i see your hand is still
up no
yes it is yeah yeah very much so thank
you very much i'm grateful for mr dodson
for clarifying that particularly about
the planning training as well because
that's actually a wall of the council
not mine
all right thank you councillor none
you've got your hand up again i've
although you spoke once i hear your game
i i do beg your pardon chairman i'm i'm
a bit confused
um so it's a complete it's compulsory
training but not compulsory attendance
it hasn't been proposed and it hasn't
been seconded yet
no i'm trying to work out what it is
though joe
uh i think he's suggesting that
compulsory attendance where relevant be
agreed
which chairman has got to be on
compulsory training
chairman if you'd like let me come back
and i think councilman
nunn makes a good point and i think
that's the stamp alludes to an even
better one
what we're saying is is that the train
is compulsory
but the attendance at the training isn't
so you've got to have the training
and it just gives the flexibility
chairman to members who are working
and have got other commitments to do the
training and i'm sure
i'm sure that mr dotson as i said before
and uh and miss hughes will work very
hard
to accommodate the needs of all the
members on this training
but um chairman other than that i
certainly support this
recommendation with all the amendments
because i'm sure we're all keen to move
on thank you
yes we are indeed thank you so tara do
we have a copy of those uh
have you been able to cobble anything
together on those um
chairman in respect of recommendation
three and
the proposal from council siddal was
that we removed the reference to
consultation with the leader of the
council
and replace that with a member training
working group
made up with the leader of the council
and chairman of all committees that's my
understanding of his proposal
and council fluke did make a proposed
change to counter to recommendation
to to change the word of my
understanding to change the word
attendance to training
and again they both need the second in
chairman thank you
do i have a seconder for those two
that's fine right i think you'll find i
seconded little three
at the time thank you yes apologies
for the thompson is that a legacy hand
no actually chairman um it isn't i was
only going to say
and and i'm sure mr johnson and ms
hughes will have this under control but
i would be anxious that we don't have to
have too many sessions in order
to accommodate all members and
the rest of their lives i appreciate the
difficulties especially if people are
working
but what we don't want is to run several
sessions for
uh you know one and two one or two
members but as i say i'm sure mr dodson
will come up with something he always
does
thank you all right thank you very much
uh
any other people who wish to speak i
can't see anybody else
no chairman i've got another hands up
okay in that case
i'm going to go to uh the vote for those
recommendations
as amended are members happy to agree
those by ascent
agree a great
that is agreed then thank you very much
members we'll move on now just before
you move on
and were members looking to um
did i just want to check and respect the
working group it was just the leader of
the council and the chairman of all
committees
that was that correct that's my
understanding of it that's fine
that's great i did also say the deputy
leader as well miss buddha
i did think i'd met him for something
thank you very much is that okay to make
that amendment chairman
yes is that all agreed members thank you
all right i'll set up that agreement
yeah i agree thank you
yes thank you very much
we move on now to agenda item 12.
these are the elections um scheduled for
the 6th
of may um in a moment again i'll call on
the leader to present this item
members if you wish to speak please use
the hands up function and i'll come to
you please keep your points clear
and succinct leader please introduce the
report
um yeah thank you chair and obviously
members the purpose of the report is
quite self-explanatory
um we're looking to delegate the
authority to the council's returning
officer
to decide on an alternative polling
station at the forthcoming elections
in may 2021 in the event of any
designated venues not being
available for use i think i'm going to
let mr dodson speak
because i think there may be some issues
some of it is clear on the report but he
may have some updates
the recommendation that i am proposing
chairman and i will need a second
therefore
is that the returning that for the
elections being held on the 6th of may
2021 the council delegates authority to
the returning officer
to decide on a suitable alternative
venue
should any designated polling station
become unavailable
do i have a secondary yes secondly
thank you thank you i think you do i
think uh the first one was councillor
swain actually
can i hand over now to um mr dodson
please
and and before i do shut up cher can i
thank mr dodson for coming
to attend this meeting because he was
supposed to be on leave
so thank you mr dodson
yes we do thank you mr dodson are you uh
able to uh continue yes thank you
chairman um yes as the leader said this
is a fairly um
self-explanatory report in the
we normally bring through council the
the list of polling places and the the
last review took place in 2019 and
councillor
approved the the list of polling
stations that we use
um in the run-up to the elections that
are due to be held at the start of may
we've obviously contacted all of the
polling stations with a view to booking
them
for that election and the the initial
response was
was um very slow it's actually improved
from
when the report was written but there
still are two
um polling stations outstanding that
we've not been able to
confirm so um given the
the need to plan and the additional
planning
um in fact that we'll go into this
election
um that's why we're seeking the
delegation to be able to
relocate those polling stations if
required
there'll be significant work over and
above the normal
um election preparation to be undertaken
if the election is to go ahead in early
may
including making all of those polling
stations covered safe
etc so you know it's not just a matter
of a couple of them that aren't
confirmed
we'll be doing risk assessments of each
of the polling stations to ensure
that they're fit for purpose under the
new conditions under which
we're operating so um that that's why
we're seeking the the delegation
thank you thank you very much i'm now
going to invite members to make any
comments on the report
tara can you uh indicate anyone who
wishes to speak please
uh yes chairman a councillor mrs
thompson and councillor mrs channel have
both indicated their wish to speak
oh and councillor fluker thank you
chairman thank you
councillor thompson first please thank
you chairman um
i'm actually quite surprised this isn't
already built into the constitution
although
having said that we don't normally have
to cope with these pandemics
um i would say yes mr dodson
i'm sure uh would be helped by all the
flexibility we can possibly give him and
i absolutely support this thank you
thank you very much councillor chana um
yes chairman
i don't wish to repeat what mrs
thompson's uh counsel mrs thompson has
said but yes mr dodson
um he's coming tonight for a meeting i
think we need to make sure perhaps
he does take some time off because i i
would not relish
his position actually and what he may
have to do and achieve so this is very
very sound very very sensible
and um bearing in mind the role he's got
to play in the elections then we need to
give him
all the assistance we can and he's got
to move quickly on occasions
so this is a very sound move to ensure
he's got that delegated responsibility
thank you very much councillor fluker
german i apologize my hand is down
okay thank you um i think uh is it
cancer
no okay any other any other members um
tara i don't know that appears to be
everyone wants to speak
thank you i've just put my hand up can i
have a piece of counselor bill's
chocolate please she's sitting there
eating chocolate he's making us all very
hungry german
okay so i'm satisfied then all members
have had an opportunity to speak on this
can we agree that by a cent please
yes agreed
thank you very much you can
see my cartoon agreement because i've
copied counselor durham's because it's
very elegant so
i've got it here
it's a good thing to have very
professional thank you thank you very
much
uh a gender item 13 questions to the
leader in accordance with procedure
rule 1 3m if any member has a question
for the leader of the council
please use the hands up function to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
uh councillor thompson
thank you chairman thank you leader um
it's been announced that the district
no longer has a five-year land supply
and that inevitably will become
vulnerable
to speculative planning applications can
you tell our residents what steps you'll
be taking to protect and already
overstretch schools and doctor surgeries
from what is likely to be the effect of
potentially hundreds more houses
thank you
yeah thank you i don't know if we want
to go to mr dodson
before i speak just in case he wishes to
do an update on that but i can
personally say that have
made um try to make contact through
essex county council
regarding school places already i
haven't had a reply back
our offices are working officers are
working hard
to try and get the five-year land supply
back again but we all know
it's not necessarily our fault we do
know that
developers can slow down building we
know there's a shortages of
bricks roof trusses etc councillor
thompson
so it could we also could impact and
fall below again this time
um there was some news out today um and
i think hopefully
mr lee might have read this it came out
in the planning portal
that two spec gladmans of this world
had just lost a high court case because
they would
it had gone on to high court to say that
two councils
had gone below the five-year land supply
and it states quite clearly that the
mppf
um goes in the resumption of um
development doesn't it
and they lost the case uh i don't know
if mr lee is on the call i've actually
printed it off and i've got it here if
he hasn't read it
but they lost the case so yes it is it
is important and i take on board the
question
cancer thompson and we'll do everything
we can the school places yes we are
we are trying to get some more um
contact made with the powers that be
but don't forget when this ldp was
agreed
we know that the our infrastructure was
going to create we've maxed it out
basically and i think mr leafy is on the
call he'll be able to back me up on that
mr lee or mr dodson
thank you um leader if i can come in
first with your through you
chairman um i just wanted to highlight
that yes
the the five-year housing land supply um
obviously
um we have fallen uh just below that
i wanted to highlight as well though
that we have achieved
ironically the best result in terms of
the housing delivery test
um that we have um over the
life of this this ldp and i think for
the third year in a row we passed
the housing delivery test um building
over
in excess of 400 houses within the
district up to
march this year so the problem hasn't
been with
um delivering um the problem has been
with
the hold ups we're now facing and the
issues uh around approvals
and uh um bringing forward the
um those those um applications that have
already been approved with those being
brought into the pipeline
but we have already been doing work um
looking at this
um but i'll hand over to mr lee to
provide a bit more detail on the
background of that
thank you thank you chairman um
the uh couple of points there um in
relation to counter stamp i am aware of
the high court judgment
and it's confirmation of the primacy of
the
uh local plan um i haven't made the
whole judgment yet i've
read a quick summary of here um just to
be honest i'm not quick
not particularly surprised at the
outcome because it's a basic point of
planning law that you know the
development plan is the starting point
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise and the mppf as it
acknowledges itself it's just a
material situation but i will be fully
familiarize myself with it and i can
guarantee members that obviously as and
when it helps us defend
robust or that helps us to finally
robustly defend uh
add to sale planning applications that
we have great concerns with we will be
doing that um
offices are looking at uh ways of
trying to support the delivery of
housing to ensure that we do have five
year land spines obviously
it's fairly early on so there's not
really much i can say in that instance
in relation to infrastructure such as
education
and highways and all other such things
that is a material consideration
determination of any plan application
any shortfall or harm
potentially would adversely would be so
significant that it would go
to such a degree that it would outweigh
any benefits to them so in theory that
would still be a reason for refusal so
i can ensure all members that take into
account the likelihood of some very
significant developments coming forward
that the officers will be working with
our partners such as essex county
council in relation to schools or
escalating to highways or the nhs etc to
ensure that
infrastructure and services are there
and if they aren't there
um whether or not the development can
one of the best phrase wash its own face
to mitigate the harm or whether
actually that will form a reason for
refusal but i can ensure that officers
will take that all in
but it is very early so it's hard to
actually give any specifics
so i hope i've assisted members and at
least delayed some of the fears
thank you chairman thank you mr lee and
councillor
oh thank you chairman sorry my princess
going berserk again
i've got a couple of questions chairman
um
counselor jana sorry sorry around your
loud one
oh i i thought we could ask any
questions
when i tried to with cancer fluka when
he was the leader and bob was the check
counsellor boyce was the chairman
i was categorically told one you're
allowed one question
i'm i'm going by the constitution and it
doesn't say there is a
um a sort of gathering on that i i think
i can ask you and i think
yes please i think councilman
actually can i just pause you there
please can we go to mr quelch can you
help us out with that please mr crouch
it's kind of put you on the spot what
what can you ask your first question
please yeah i mean i
i'm sorry chairman yes i'm just looking
at the constitution now i mean
my from recollection i think mrs channer
is right
i don't think there is a limitation um
naturally chairs can control
the way a council meeting runs
um but let me just check that i think
it's i think i'm just trying to check it
actually at the moment
um uh uh meanwhile perhaps cancer
channel you can ask your first question
yeah
it's rule it's rule six bracket seven is
monitoring obviously
that is very helpful thank you um yes
thank you my first question is
um leader do you agree with me that the
protocols of the council
should be followed and that in public
meetings members should address officers
in accordance with the rules agreed by
council
is there a point behind that council
channel but
yes we have to adhere to the rules
so i would imagine there is a follow-up
to that
no the next question is totally
different that was just that one
if mr quelch says i can ask another i
believe i can but i'll wait till the
monitoring officer comes back if you'd
like check
council channel please feel free i can
only tell you what happened when i
wanted to ask previous questions i'm
absolutely fine with the chancellor
channel but i'd like consistency
chairman can i perhaps um give you my
view
on that there's no restriction in the
count in the procedure rules um
rule six talks about rule six talks
about obviously questions being
asked and controls what can be asked and
then
if you go to rule 1 3
m it just says a limitation on the
amount of time of 15 minutes so it
doesn't say
it's one question per counsellor now
there may be a situation where there's
lots of questions and on previous
occasions
previous chairman has said look for all
for all members to
uh to ask there at least one question
because of the 15-minute rule
i'm restricting you to one question so
that that may be the case but
there is nothing in the council
procedure all was that restricts
um to one question okay i mean
i'm happy yeah go ahead with your second
question counselor
thank you very much um mr chairman um
leader um recently i received an email
which had the parish council forum
agenda with it which i found very
interesting especially as there was the
body on it
which actually i sit on the board of one
of the items comes under the auspices of
that
um going back to the fifth of november
meeting when councils were asked anybody
that any outside body or whatever they
sit on if they could bring the minutes
back in
to the authority that would be helpful
i've looked for the parish council forum
minutes actually on the idrive
and wherever this central depository is
that all minutes will go to and i
couldn't find any
so really my point is does the leader
agree with me that it would be helpful
for minutes of the parish council forum
meetings
to be available to all members because
i've certainly been asked about parish
council
forum and had questions asked about
what's been said in it
but i can't find the minutes anywhere so
that's my question would it be
beneficial to members
who have to represent their electorate
if they're posed questions to be aware
of what the parish
council forums discussed and what the
minutes state about that meeting that
would be helpful
thank you council channel excellent
question i don't see a problem but we'd
have to check the constitution or the
terms of reference
i personally received the minutes from
the last parish council meeting
i think yesterday or today so that they
have been published
and i will speak to the offices after
this meeting and the person who issued
them
and but i certainly don't have a problem
cancer china but obviously i'll have to
check with
what it states in the constitution uh
but yeah
yeah you know done well but not excuse
my language you know well that i really
think everybody should be included in
most things thank you leader very much
appreciated thank you
thank you very much tomorrow please
sorry councilman morris can i speak
please chairman
yes i'll put you on the list no problem
uh councillor and bill was next
you you're muted counsellor bill
i wasn't i am all that chocolate's gone
to my head
cause you didn't
housing land supply and i'm wondering
what we're actually doing to actually
increase that
whether or not mr dodson or matt would
have to answer that
and is it because that there doesn't
seem to be much happening at all
with the haybridge um garden suburb
i'm sorry chairman i missed cancer
bill's first question first bits of the
question
could you be wondering what we're
actually doing
to get us back to our five-year land
supply
and possibly through you
if that has been caused by the lack of
action in the haybridge garden suburb
north haybird's garden suburb okay thank
you
this is an excellent question i think mr
lee needs to answer that because it's
very similar to the first
first question even though it doesn't
target education etc
and infrastructure improvements but mr
lee could you help um
cancel it beale for me please through
you chairman um
there's a number of things officers are
doing obviously
it's we're fairly early in the process
you know i think it was
around a month ago um it was published
that we had lost our five-year land
supply so
and obviously a lot of this is
market-led so there's only limited
things we can do and
members will be aware from various
committees there are
a couple of options that we have
discussed obviously have been discussed
under confidential paper so i won't
progress on them any further um
but membership members are aware that
and there have been a number of
pre-application queries that have come
in
in light of which we'll see also our
confidential in light of the fact that
we are no longer able to demonstrate
five land supply and obviously officers
are providing guidance and advice in
relation to them
um in relation to specifics about why we
no longer have a five-year land supply
um personally i think honestly it's very
difficult for any authority to retain
its five-year land supply
um we are struggling partly i think
because
as you know we've discussed previously
that one of the allocated sites hasn't
come forward and is unlikely to at all
potentially um having limited
large sites which you know slows down
delivery
in relation to the site specific um
obviously it's a large site has a large
number of dwellings it has come forward
slower than we would hoped
so that impacts on it but i don't think
you can ever point your finger at one
side and say that's the reason one of
the other reasons but as
mr dodson highlights actually we've
built a lot of houses and actually
obviously once you've started building
them
they're no longer there to be built in
the future which is a problem because
the government has slightly changed the
wording
about how you work out your five-year
land supply which has
made it a little bit more difficult for
us but i think generally is going to be
a
difficult position for most authorities
particularly us going forward and
it is something we will need to look at
probably not just this year but
at least next year as well thank you
chairman all right thank you
so questions against the leader
councillor helm
thank you mr chairman through you mr
chairman
um first of all i'd like to point out
some of the leader
that the questions are to the leader
not for everyone else to answer for you
can always come back later
and say i'll give you a written response
okay
would you like me to answer that before
you move on to the question
well i think i i think i can answer that
uh
although i'll i'll defer to you leader
i don't mind if you want to answer it um
cancer helm i did ask the same question
this morning
i was told i couldn't reply in writing
and i was told it was well within the
uh the rights of the leaders if i had to
seek some
um other advice from officers that was
that was allowed so thank you for
bringing that
point thank you very
have to you've much me a question please
let me finish
thank you yeah so
so it has been checked out and we all
are above board thank you so your second
question
thanks the next one refers to i'm sure
you agree with me
that you at a recent leaders speech you
made a comment about openness and
transparency
we both attended a recent working group
meeting
where the chairman made an apology which
i rejected and that has been
hasn't coming out in the minutes yet can
you agree with me that we ensure that
that goes in the minutes when we have
the next meeting
um it's not down to me to say what goes
in the minutes is it it's it's not down
to the leader i don't take the minutes
i think you've spoken to me about this
on a separate occasion
and i actually asked you counsellor helm
what
the counsellor actually did say and you
didn't recollect what he's
what the has said i don't recollect what
the council has said so
please take that up with the minute
secretary and the chairman of that
[ __ ] group i was about to say i think
that's going to be for the for the
members to agree that
okay chairman chairman i'd like to ask
how long this session's been going on
for it feels like it's a grilling
which i'm absolutely fine about but how
long has it been taken
is it going on are we up to the 15
minutes because there's still many hands
yeah i do you see there are some more
hands uh provided
members your questions are brief and to
the point
uh i i will allow that councillor morris
you're next
oh okay thank you chairman um
this isn't really a question this is
just uh something i would like to state
and on the minutes
i'd like to thank councillor stamp for
actually taking questions and i would
like to remind the other councillors
mostly councillor helm and councillor
channel
that when the council of fluker was in
the seat sometimes i'd ask him questions
and he wouldn't even open his mouth
so uh it's it's funny now once you were
the dog
now you're the lamp post all right okay
uh councillor chairman i take exception
to that comment
i hope you will deal with that
accordingly chairman i have to say
accordingly
your question chairman thank you
chairman
uh through through you uh uh to the
leader
um many years ago the council resolved
um to give electric car owners
free car parking to my memory
that has not been rescinded
leader um can i
do not expect you to answer this
question because obviously i'm talking
of history and
so on um but would you have this uh
checked out and i was reminded of this
by the earlier
debate on climate change thank you
leader
thank you councillor boyce excellent of
course i will and i'm sure that we can
make sure it happens
mr dodson can't win our new climate
strategy as far as possible
thank you um next question
are we up to 15 minutes the constitution
i don't want to break the constitution
chairman no i understand that i think
that is
for uh the the leaders speech will be
time limited the budget speech to 15
minutes
mr quelch we got a time limit on this
sorry chairman i'm just looking at the
um again the procedurals let me just
double check this um i think it's in one
it's one
it's in it's in rule one and let me just
double double check it
um yeah i mean i think you'll find it
says 15 minutes
but at the discretion of the chair
absolutely counselor boys has beaten me
to it
all right okay well in that case we have
had over 17 minutes
uh and i'm going to call that session to
a close thank you very much
we're going to move on now to a
well the other thing that i would say is
if you haven't generally that is the
most
democratic thing i think you've ever
ever
said shame on you shame on you shame on
you
16 which is their housing market reports
referring back to that last point if you
have any questions for the leader
please email them in however i do want
to move on
so we're moving on to agenda item 16
the housing market
it's a gender item 14 we need to do
which is the urgent business and then we
need to go through the exclusion of the
public and press
right yeah i'm sorry i've gone ahead of
myself
um business by reason of special
circumstances considered by
the chairman to be urgent i have none
i therefore turn to agenda item 15
and this is where we now have to go into
closed session
and the exclusion of the press and
public
and i move that under section 100 a
of the local government act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
the following items of business
on the grounds that they involve the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraphs
three of part one of schedule 12a
to the act and this satisfied the public
interest is that seconded councillor
maze
thank you and uh agreed members
agreed age agreed
agreed thank you we will now
pause um until we have confirmation
that the public have left german can we
have a comfort break please chair
uh yes okay um
five minutes thank you